more than 30 years after its release
Steven Spielberg's classic ET captures
the imagination of new fans around the
world and remains one of the most
beloved films of all time let's take a
look back at some of the talented cast
members who helped make it such a
success and find out what they're up to
today
[Music]
Henry Thomas's role as Elliot in ET
launched him to stardom practically
overnight while still a child actor
Thomas starred in a number of other
movies including the 1984 adventure film
cloak and dagger with Dabney Coleman
Thomas made a successful transition to
adult roles in the early 1990s and has
appeared in dozens of films and
television shows since then including
fire in the sky legends of the fall
kings of New York and without a trace in
addition to his acting talents Thomas is
also a musician one of his songs was
even used for the soundtrack of 1997's
Niagara Niagara in which he also starred
in 2017 Thomas appeared in Netflix's
adaptation of Gerald's game and in a
recurring role on the FX comedy drama
better things other roles include the
Netflix horror series the haunting of
Hill House as well as a pair of projects
with director Mike Flanagan the Netflix
series Midnight Mass and The Shining
sequel dr. sleep in which Thomas
appeared as the spirit of Jack Torrance
the mind is a blackboard and this is the
eraser like many girls her age Elliot's
little sister Gerty portrayed by Drew
Barrymore enjoys playing pretend with
her dolls and watching Sesame Street but
she isn't your typical five-year-old
quick-witted and sarcastic Gerty calls
her mother Mary and can tell when her
brothers are lying to each other Gerty
helps with chores around the house and
her mother even trusts her to stay home
alone for short periods as a member of
the famed Barrymore family of stage and
screen actors drew Barrymore successful
Hollywood career isn't surprising before
et she had a few minor film and
television parts but Barrymore's
performance as Gerty put her on the map
opening the door for starring roles in
movies like firestarter
by the end of the 1980s Barrymore was
one of Hollywood's most famous child
actors and since then she starred in
dozens of films including poison ivy the
wedding singer boys on the side and the
Charlie's Angels action franchise in
2009 Barrymore directed the roller derby
drama whippet and she's also executive
produced a number of other movies and
television shows
more recently Barrymore produced and
starred opposite Timothy Olyphant in the
Netflix dark comedy series Santa Clarita
diet she also served as a producer on
the 2019 Charlie's Angels movie and
she's joined the ranks of actors turned
talk-show host with the aptly titled the
drew Barrymore show while the role of
Tyler and ET may have been actors see
Thomas Howells first real gig it
certainly wouldn't be his last
in fact al was the only one of his
characters rowdy teenage gang to
continue acting into adulthood and since
his film debut in 1982 he's appeared in
more than 200 film and television roles
you probably remember how Liz Ponyboy
Curtis in the outsiders Lieutenant
Chamberlain in Gettysburg or officer
duddeck in the TNT crime drama Southland
more recently he's appeared in several
episodes of the Showtime series ray
Donovan as well as an arc on the
long-running crime procedural Criminal
Minds and he also starred in the shows
the terror and SEAL team in addition to
his acting chops Howell has also spent
some time in the director's chair he's
directed at least seven movies thus far
including several Mach Buster spoofs of
classic science-fiction films because of
the movies focus on Elliott's and the
other children Elliot's mother Mary
played by Dee Wallace is one of only two
significant adult characters in et in
fact other than Mary we don't even see
another adult space on screen until the
final thirty minutes of the film after
her husband goes to live with his
girlfriend in Mexico Mary struggles to
deal with the situation and her new role
as a single mother and the pressure of
providing for and raising her children
alone gets even worse after Elliot
starts behaving strangely and acting out
at school while she's afraid of et at
first Mary's heart softens toward the
alien after she sees the incredible bond
it shares with her son over her four
decade Hollywood career Dee Wallace has
appeared in well over 200
and television shows and is an icon
among horror fans for her performances
in films like howling and the hills have
eyes after playing Mary Ann et Wallace
starred in the 1983 horror film Cujo as
a mom trying to protect her son from a
rabid st. Bernard dog from 1989 to 1992
she played a mother yet again in the new
Lassie and you might also remember her
from Rob Zombie's 2007 remake of horror
classic Halloween
after a brief stint on General Hospital
that earned her a Daytime Emmy
nomination Wallace returned a horror in
early 2018 when she starred in death
house alongside several other legends of
the genre then again the following year
as part of the cast of Rob Zombie's
three from hell
along with Elliott's mother Mary the
only adult audiences get to know during
ET is a government agent portrayed by
Peter Coyote who leads the team
searching the area for any signs of ETS
whereabouts known as Keyes among et fans
for the keychain he wears coyotes
character finally meets Elliot sin ET
after the two become gravely ill while
many scientists put in such a position
might be callous or even cruel Keyes is
different he tells Eliot's about his own
childhood dreams and gives the boy a few
moments alone to mourn after ET appears
to die after Elliot sin ET escape he
rides with Mary and Gertie as they
follow the children to the forest
clearing their keys is rewarded for his
kindness by getting to witness ET saying
goodbye to his friends and leaving on
the spaceship that has returned for it
the multi-talented Peter Coyote was
still starting out as a film actor when
he was cast as keys and he's been going
strong ever since and fact he's played
well over a hundred different roles
since et including those in bitter moon
sphere a walk to remember the 4400 and
Erin Brokovich in addition to his acting
career coyote is also a published author
who is frequently contributed to Mother
Jones magazine more recently he starred
in the 2007 teen miniseries that
disappearance and the movie the
etruscans smile alongside Thora Birch
and Rosanna Arquette check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]